murray lost it
right into the hands of dwight howard
and here's westwood you know where he's
going and he scores
[Applause]
it's amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
westbrook
with the left hand this time
he's getting into the lane at the will
[Applause]
reeves swings it to westbrook
he again goes to the rim over pearl
jacob got a piece but it comes to the
hands of davis who quickly pops it back
in
three-point shooting so far this season
but i thought he had a three ball two or
three possessions ago and he didn't even
look at it that one he takes so again
bill it's i've said it several times
it's about recognition and they're not
aware of the spacing and sometimes
they're running into each other and
they're too close to each other to
really create a good looking shot
westbrook backing them down knocked away
inside
back out
plenty of time 10 on the shot clock
westbrook
hits the three that one you live with
[Applause]
not a soul around him nobody fought to
get around the screen that's just
fatigue
westbrook
four on the shot clock
[Applause]
wow what a terrific move by westbrook
[Music]
[Applause]
in there
westbrook
looking for 31
and does it with a dunk
westbrook splitting two of our guys and
before you can get to the block he's off
his feet it's just deep down the stretch
and nerve and being in that situation
before you know being ready to perform
face more than this
to follow the two on a lake early let's
get aggressive here on the defensive end
just to allow the lakers to run whatever
they want acres with westbrook trying to
add to the lead and he does
four point laker lead 125 121